-Ivanka Trump tried
to distance herself
from her father and her family's
business during her testimony
in the New York fraud
trial this week,
and yet, Trump himself
remains far ahead.
And the GOP also ran
to gather for a fiery
and mostly pointless debate
last night.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump is far and away the
front runner in the GOP primary.
He's 40 points ahead
of his nearest rival.
If you combine all his rivals,
Trump would still win.
Trump is so dominant, even his
own former vice president,
who in a normal world
might be a top contender,
just dropped out last month
and nobody noticed or cared.
Although,
I'm not sure anyone
has ever really noticed
Mike Pence.
He's the - He's the color
they paint your apartment
before you move in.
[ Laughter ]
That's how he got away
from the mob
trying to kill him
on January 6th.
He just stood on a pedestal
in the rotunda
and they thought
he was a statue.
[ Laughter ]
He's lucky that one guy
didn't try to steal him.
[ Laughter ]
So there's really no point
to continuing to hold
J.V. debates with
all the eventual losers.
The only real benefit
to these debates
is that wherever desperate
losers gather,
there's occasionally
some fireworks.
Take, for example,
entrepreneur Vivek Ramaswamy --
you know, the guy with the
energy of a Hollywood assistant
who offers you a Fiji water
while you wait,
and then tells his boss
you demanded a Fiji water.
He's the guy in a zombie movie
who says he'll get the car
and come back for everyone else,
and then he just leaves
and drives off.
But the joke's on him
because there's a zombie
in the back seat,
and when that zombie lunges
forward and bites his neck
while he screams
singing "Life Is a Highway,"
the whole audience cheers
with delight
because [bleep] that guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ramaswamy got into a heated
exchange with Nikki Haley,
who served as UN ambassador
under Donald Trump.
You don't really need to know
what this is about
because it's all
weirdo nonsense.
Except that Ramaswamy
attacked Haley's daughter
for using TikTok, and Haley
was fired up.
-In the last debate,
she made fun of me
for actually joining TikTok
while her own daughter
was actually using the app
for a long time.
So you might want to take care
of your family first.
-Leave my daughter
out of your voice.
-The next generation
of Americans are using it...
[ Audience booing ]
...and that's
actually the point.
You have her supporters
propping her up.
That's fine. Here's the truth.
-You're just scum.
[ Laughter ]
-Ramaswamy elicited
a reaction from me
that I thought was impossible
when he said,
"You might want to take care
of your family first."
I actually thought,
"Donald Trump would never!"
I mean, I'm kidding.
Of course he would.
Scum, though, scum is not a word
you tend to hear
in a lofty political debate.
I don't recall Lincoln
ever calling Douglas
a mouthy son of a bitch,
but let's face it,
this is just
what the modern GOP is:
people attacking
other people's children
in the hopes of winning an
election they've already lost.
At the next debate, I wouldn't
be shocked if Chris Christie
just broke a glass bottle
on the podium
and said, "You want to go?!
Let's go!"
This whole thing was
a demented circus.
Compare that
to the other side.
I'm pretty sure
the most impolite thing
that ever happened
in a Democratic primary debate
was Bernie putting
both fingers up in the air.
Everyone was like,
"Whoa, whoa, Bernie!
Put those things back
in their holsters!"
"I'm keeping them both up!
[ Laughter ]
And if you wonder
why I hold them for,
you can distribute them
equal amongst themselves!"
So you've got candidates
attacking each other's kids,
calling each other scum.
Meanwhile, Ron DeSantis
is just standing there
in the middle of it,
getting overshadowed
and just making weird faces
while other people talk,
I guess not realizing
he is on camera.
And the only thing stranger than
that is his complete inability
to smile like
a normal human being.
If you're trying
to convince people
that you don't wear lifts
inside your boots,
maybe don't make the
"my heels are killing me" face.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently he tried
to improve on
the off-putting smile he made
at the last debate,
but the big note he got
this time was "more tongue."
[ Laughter ]
What's wrong with this guy?
How did anyone ever think this
was the GOP's next great hope?
He's anti-woke, and he has
Fire Marshall Bill face.
[ Laughter ]
So, last night
went off the rails.
Or, rather,
there were never any rails.
Going into the debate,
Ramaswamy actually said
his goal, in order
to appeal to GOP voters,
was to act like a lunatic.
-I asked him what his campaign
strategy, his debate strategy
was going to be for tonight.
He needs something to shake
loose, to break through.
He said he wanted
to be unhinged.
-I'm sorry. Your debate
strategy...was to be unhinged?
That's not a strategy
for a debate.
That's a strategy
for getting an entire row
to yourself on the subway.
"I'll just wear
an astronaut helmet,
no pants, tell everyone
when the cockroaches
are actually CIA spies
who can read my mind,
and then I'll just put up
my feet and relax.
Who's scum now?"
[ Laughter ]
There was one thing they all
seemed to agree on, though.
They are tired of losing.
Thanks in large part to Trump,
the GOP has lost elections
in 2018,
2020, 2022
and then again this week,
and the candidates on stage
were fed up with it.
-He said Republicans were
going to get tired of winning.
Well, we saw last night,
I'm sick of Republicans losing.
-I think there's something
deeper going on
in the Republican Party here,
and I am upset about
what happened last night.
We've become a party of losers.
-And you can believe them
when they say that
because they were
at the loser debate.
[ Laughter ]
And yet most of these losers
who are tired of losing
still say they'd vote
for perennial loser Trump
if he's the nominee,
which, as of this moment
is most likely going to be
the outcome by a mile.
In fact, Trump has taken
to belittling
his so-called opponents
and making fun of just
how far behind him they are,
like Ron DeSantis.
He's coming up with
strange new metaphors
to explain what exactly happened
to DeSantis.
-You know that I endorsed Ron,
and he went from
having very little
to having a lot
and got him elected.
He said, "They like you
in Florida, sir, very much.
I think that I could..."
Tears flowing from his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
It's true.
"I need your endorsement, sir.
I need your endorsement,
please."
They said,
"Governor, you're gonna run
against the president."
He said, "I have no comment!
I have no comment."
I said, "Wow, no comment?
That means he's going
to run to me."
And I said,
"Let's hit him hard right now."
And my people said, "Sir,
don't hit him.
He's a Republican."
I said, "I don't care
if he's a Republican,"
and we hit him hard,
and now he's like a wounded,
falling bird from the sky.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I like
this new poetic Trump.
[ Laughter ]
He should do his next rally
at a public reading
in the East Village.
[ Laughter ]
"He's like a wounded,
falling bird from the sky.
And through the air
he doth pass by...
beating his wings to no avail.
Upon these wings,
he once did sail...
from under heaven
to ashen earth...
ending in death
where he began in birth.
And so I said once he was gone,
'Here lies...
sad little...Meatball Ron.'"
[ Laughter, applause ]
Trump, of course, is dealing
with his own set of problems,
like his indictments, which he
complained about yet again
during a competing rally held
during last night's
loser debate.
Although, he's also come up
with a new twist
on his indictment rant as well.
-Every time
the radical left Democrats,
Marxists, communists
and fascists indict me --
They indicted me!
Can you believe? --
my father and mother
are looking down,
"Son, how did that happen?
We're so proud of you, son.
How did that happen?"
-"We're so proud of you."
Trump even makes dead people
say nice things about him.
"The other day,
a ghost came up to me --
big ghost, dead ghost,
see-through tears
flowing down his spectral face
and onto his jangling chains --
and he said to me, 'Sir,
I owe you an apology, sir.
Me and all my dead friends
in Pennsylvania
voted for Joe Biden.'"
"The Washington Post"
reported this week
that Trump apparently has a plan
in place to punish critics
and get revenge using
the Justice Department
if he wins another term.
And at his rallies,
he's been announcing
that he'll go after Joe Biden
for unspecified crimes.
Although, he can't even say
what Biden supposedly did
or what laws
he supposedly broke.
-We will start by exposing
every last crime committed
by crooked Joe Biden,
because now that he indicted me,
we're allowed to look at him.
But he did real bad things.
-Well, so much for poet Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Guess he had
"Gilligan's Island" syndrome,
where a coconut fell on his head
and he became smart for a day,
then another coconut
fell on his head
and he went back
to talking like a moron.
"He did real bad things.
He's a...bad man. Fire bad."
Of course, Trump is angry
not just about
the four indictments,
but also the civil fraud trial
in New York,
which threatens to wipe out
his entire business empire.
Yesterday, his daughter Ivanka
testified and, unlike Trump
who threw a temper tantrum
and also at one point
basically confessed to adjusting
the value of his assets,
Ivanka was very evasive.
-The questions have
focused on her time
at the Trump Organization.
She left the family business
in 2017
when she went
to the White House.
But the government has been
asking her questions
about specific projects that she
worked on while she was there.
-Ivanka Trump testifying
that she had no role
in her father's personal
financial statements.
-Ivanka Trump saying
at least 30 times
she does not recall details
about e-mails, meetings,
conversations or documents
from her time with the company.
-I expect that she
is going to try to do
as little as possible
to inflame her father,
but also to distance herself
from any --
any questions
that the AG would have.
-Oh, come on, you can't
distance yourself from him now.
You campaigned for him, worked
in the White House with him,
you sat next to him
at the boardroom table.
You can't suddenly say,
"I wasn't involved.
All I know is..."
-He did real bad things.
-Trying to distance yourself
from your father now is absurd.
The only distance between Ivanka
and her father is the distance
between the quality
of their courtroom sketches.
Here's an Ivanka sketch,
which seems like
a reasonably fair depiction.
Now, compare that
to Trump's sketch.
Yah!
[ Laughter ]
He looks like one
of those freaky little demons
from a Hieronymus Bosch
painting.
I almost feel like whoever
did that Ivanka sketch
made sure to do a good job
just to make Trump's look
even worse by comparison.
They even gave her papers
to read.
They might as well have also
given her a word bubble
that says "I'm smart"
and given him a dunce cap.
[ Laughter ]
The self-professed party losers
lost big yet again on Tuesday,
and they're all angry about it,
but they have no solutions.
Their front runner
is still Donald Trump,
who's still facing
four criminal cases
and is still very unpopular
outside of the Republican Party.
That doesn't mean he can't win,
but if he loses
and he gets convicted,
there's a good chance
we will finally see...
-Tears flowing from his eyes.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody. Thanks
for watching "A Closer Look."
And as a reminder,
my brother, Josh, and I
have started a new podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
We hope you listen, we hope
you like it, and see you soon.